サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダナサーサナン
では 今年も皆様方には大変幸せな
悩み苦しみのない 頑張る勇気が出てくる年になりますようにと
まず祝福をいたしまして
今日の話 テーマについて話します
で 今日はまあお正月になってくる
誰でもまあ幸福を祈願する時期になりますので
まあいわゆる幸福上ですね
私の言葉で言えば そういう時期ですから
それに合わせてお釈迦様の言葉を紹介したいと思います
今日は私のポイントは
この副題で書いている
この生かされることと生きること
これ 日本語でよく人気のあるフレーズフレーズで生かされる
生かされるというのは
なんかすごい偉いことを言っているような気持ちで言ってますからね
まあ生きるということはそれほど興味は
人気はないんですけど
ありがたく生かされているんだよという場合は
かなりなんかかっこいいことを言っているような気分になっちゃうんですね
この両方合わせて調整することが
まあ幸福の道であるというテーマで喋りたいとは思っています
はい そういうことで まずは心
どうして仏教の話っていうのは
ブッダの話っていうのは心のお話になりますから
これはまず理解しておきましょう
生きているということは心ですからね
だから幸せになりたいと思うのも心でしょうし
私はあんまりうまくいってないんだと思うのは自分の心でしょうし
だから心がなければ何も成り立ちませんね
だから変な迷信を捨てちゃって
すごい具体的に まあおいしいご飯を食べたいと思うのは自分の心でしょうし
だから口があっただけでご飯をおいしく感じませんよ
心が働いてくれないと
口が生きていないと で
感覚が生まれないと 口の中でおいしくはならないんですね
そういうわけで 私たちはもうやっているすべてのことは
心が中心に 心の指導で起きているもので
結局心がやっているんですね
私はよく言うことは こうやって手を動かすことを思う
この機械じゃないんですよ
それを動かしたいという心があって
そこから命令されて手を動かしているんですね
そういうことで 例えばこの机は自分勝手には動かないんですね
しかし 我々人間の心にはこれを動かしたいという気持ちが起こると
それでも勝手に動かないんですね
そうすると私たちは自分でこれを手で持って動かしたりするんですね
そういうことで そちらでこの指導者が誰かというと心なんですよ
そういうことで心のことを学ばなきゃどうにもならんですよ
それで心っていうのはいつでも変で
迷信で もう勘違いで間違ったことばっかり考えているんだから
まあ幸福っていうのは神から授かるものやとかね
とにかく迷信の世界に行っちゃうんですね
信仰の方に行っちゃうんですね
で そこは本当に結果があるかないかとね
客観的に 科学的に調べることでしょうに
だから神がに授かった子供だと言うならば
ちょっと実験してみたら
まあ十八ぐらいの女の子を選んでね
ずっともうまあ五年間ぐらいね
あるいは十年間でもいいんだから
祈りだけしてくださいと
真面目に神様に妊娠するのかと
それで祈りだけで 他の何の関係もなく妊娠したら
まあ科学的に証明されたことになるでしょうに
だからなんでそこまでおかしいのかとね
もう何回も子供をおろしたりもしてね
それで経済的に状況が安定したところで子供を産んで
ああ これ授かった子供やとか何言うんですかね
今まであんたどれ何人か
どれくらい赤ちゃんをおろしたんですかと聞きたくなりますけどね
だからこの頭が変なんですね
そういうことで 世の中いろんな変なことばっかり言って言って
あまりもうるさく言うんだから
私たちも洗脳されちゃって
それが事実であると で
勘違いしているんですね
そこをきれいに 百パーセント客観的で科学的な現実の世界に人間をなんとかしてでも入ってほしいというのは
お釈迦様の仏教なんですね
だから仏教はいろいろありますから
もともとお釈迦様なんですけど
お釈迦様の教をね いろいろ人々は勝手に使ったりして
仏教っていうものはたくさん世の中にありますよ
国によって違うし その一つの国でも宗派によって仏教が違うし
例えば同じ大乗仏教といっても
ティベットの人々の仏教と日本人の仏教はまた違うし
中国や台湾でやっている仏教はまた違うしね
ベトナムやらね そういうところも大乗仏教なんですけど
全くそれでも仏教は変わっていくんですね
で それはまあ宗教学の世界で
しかし お釈迦様は宗教を教えていないんですね
全くもう ただ具体的に現実の話をしただけで
それからすべて証拠で証拠を出して立証するんですね
私たちにも鵜呑みにするんじゃなくて
立証しなさいよと 自分で確かめて発見しなさいよという
科学のアプローチなんですね
まあ科学よりすごい厳しいだけなんですね
百パーセント客観性なければいけないということ
だから そういうふうに見てみると
お釈迦様は何の躊躇もなく心という問題が出すんですね
だから ある人が生命を作って創造して生命を維持管理する人は誰ですか？と
生命の運命をね ちゃんと握って司っている人は誰ですか？と質問したんですよ
これは明らかに現代のキリスト教やらイスラム教の方から聞くような質問なんですね
そうすると キリスト教の方は神様だと言うし
イスラムの方はアッラーであると言っちゃうしね
全てその神がやってるんだと
同じ質問をお釈迦様に聞いたら
お釈迦様はどう答えるかというと
知っているに言えている
こうで 全ての物事を作るのは心でしょうし
心によってみんなもう左右されちゃって
心次第で生きているんだよと
それは立証できる話でしょうに
私たちは手を挙げたら
それ心の命令で手を挙げたんであって
決してアメテラスオオカミ様の希望通りにやったわけじゃないんです
で 結婚相手は神様が選んでくれたんじゃなくて
そこら辺で もしかすると神社で見つかったかもしれませんだけど
で 神社で拾った相手と結婚したんだと
結局は自分でやってるんですよ
自分で選んで で そちらに何の証拠もない神秘的な解説を入れて自分を誤魔化したりする
その理由は今日説明する時間ではないので
ただ心を学びましょう
心が命っていうものなんですね
そこで心の働きをよく学んで
心のプロになったら 自分好きなようにそれ使えるんですよ
どんなもののプロになったらいいでしょうに
車の運転のプロになったら
まあ自分好きなように運転できるでしょうに
オフだなくても あの 無事故で目やがんで運転できますよ
だから仏教徒になるということは
やっぱり心のプロになることなんですよ
何か信仰することじゃないんです
何か信じるとかね はないんです
はい そういうことで心の話に入ります
まず心の葛藤というテーマになります
意識はある程度で制御できます
私たちの意識がありますね
それはある程度で制御できます
あまり説明しなくても皆様わかることやと思いますけどね
こんなこと考えてる場合じゃないやとかね
テレビ見ている場合じゃないや
今は仕事に行かなくちゃとかね
で まあテレビ見ている場合じゃなくても
時間になったんだからお風呂に入らなくちゃとか
自分たちで自分の意識を制御しているんです
そこでテレビ見たいな
番組が面白いなという気持ちもあるし
でも時計見たらそんなことやってる場合じゃないし
それだったらじゃあ別なことをしましょうということで
私たちは日常生活の中で
いつでもある程度で自分の意識を制御しているんですね
だから意識を制御することは暗い単語じゃないんですよ
いつでもより良いいいことに入れようとしているんですね
例えば 子供が宿題をやる時間なのに
宿題をやらないでテレビの漫画を見ている場合は
心の制御はないんですね
だから面白いことをやっちゃいます
宿題は面白くないと そこで我々理性のある人々は
子供がやっていることは正しくないと言うでしょうね
しかし 面白い漫画あるのにも関わらず
お母さんにこれビデオ撮ってくださいと頼んで
自分が宿題する子供がまあ立派でしょ
まあ比較的に だから宿題終わってから見ますか
けど番組が終わってますから
その間ではね それでお母さんがそこはもう録画して置いておくと
あるいは自分ででもね
録画するようにね もうここをセッティングして
自分がもう宿題をやる
その子は自分の気持ちをある程度で制御してますね
漫画も見たい しかし宿題もやらなくちゃいけない
でも時間的にはちょっと問題がある
ではどうすればよろしいかと
あ この方法でうまくいくんじゃないかなと
だからそれも心の成果なんですよ
だから制御っていうのは悪いことじゃないんです
制御するとちゃんと良い結果
いつでも出してくれます
はい それで私たちにはある程度で心の制御できます
完璧にはできないんですね
だから人生はある程度でうまくいってますけど
ある程度他はうまくいってないんですね
だから皆様の人生が幸福かそうでないかという決める場合
いたって簡単ですよ あなたにどのぐらい自分の心の制御できますかと
ぴったし そのぐらい幸せになったり
不幸になったりするんです
ぴったしですよ もう数学にこういう気持ちの世界だから当てはめられる
数学にすることは不可能だけなんですけど
すごいデジタル的にわかるんです
数学的に もし心の制御するレベルに科学心理学者がデジタル的に数字を与えることできたならば
0 から 1000 とかまでね
そうするともう 100
全はトップで 100 まで制御できる人は幸福程度も 100 までなっちゃうんですね
で 完全に 1000 まで心の制御できた人が
まあそこ幸福度も全部完璧になってくるんです
だからブッダの教えっていうのは
本当にこのデジタル的に説明できるものなんです
神秘はないんです 私たちの問題は
このデジタルにしていないんですね
心 幸せになりたいんだけどねというだけでね
気持ちだけで あと具体的にどうなりたいかと
デジタルにしないと デジタルにしたら大したことじゃないんですよ
ぼーっとして大雑把で幸せになりたいな
楽しく生活したいなとかね
そう思っちゃうと もう現実的に実行は不可能なんですね
例えばどこか行きたいなと思ったら
どこにも行けないでしょ
休みでしょし どこか行きたいなとか
どこにも行けないで  1日中部屋の中でいる羽目になっちゃうんです
なぜかというと あれは気持ちだけでデジタルにしていないんですね
そこで東京に住んでいる方だったら
どこか行きたいなとか
じゃああの 上野公園にでも行こうかな
まあ公園は古くて面白くないんだかなと
まあ鎌倉どうですかね
まあちょっと遠いし 時間
そうやって考えたら じゃあ代々木公園の方がいいんじゃないかなと
決めたらもうデジタルでしょ
それ出ていて 電車に乗って行けばいいんだから
そうすると自分の希望がもう現実的に実行して
もう自分がもうどこか出かけて楽しみたいなと思ったことは
もうもうちゃんと実ってますよ
もう叶えてるんですよ
だから希望を叶えるっていうことは
そんな大したことじゃないんですよ
ただ 物事をしっかりとデジタルにしてほしいんですよ
これが宗教は大反対でしょ
だから人類にあってはならないのは宗教と組織なんですよ
はちゃめちゃにするんですね
何としてもデジタルにしてくれないんですね
全て大ざっぱにする 神を信仰したっても
私が死んじゃったら必ず天国に行きますか？と聞いたら
それはあなた決めるものじゃない
それは神様が決めるんだと
そんなやつ勝手に決めるんだったら
こちら別に信仰したっても保証がないんだから
結婚相手に見つかる場所っていうのはパワースポットありますね
出雲神社とかね で 必ず女性の方々がそちらに行ってお祈りしたら
結婚する相手見つかるならば
まあ行くのは一向に構わない
でもそこはもうデジタルにしてないんです
で なんとか日本人だからってこれをデジタルにしようと商売しようと思っていて
テレビで見たんですよ
まず女の子たちが何かお札みたいな何かを買うんですね
で それを薄い紙ですけど
それは池があって この池にこの紙を入れて
上に 100円玉を 100
円玉を入れる場所もちゃんと印刷していますね
そちらに 100円玉を入れるんですね
そこでさっさと紙が下へ沈んだら
もう早くも結婚できると
なかなか下へ進まないと
まあちょっと遅くなるんだというね
もう勝手なことを考えちゃうんですね
で そこで私に見えたのは
人間の脳がデジタルでないと働かないんですよ
宗教がものすごく中途半端でいい加減なんですね
出雲神社お神壇だからといって
結婚相手見つかるという保証っていうのはゼロ皆無なんです
そこを人間がなんとなく中途半端なところでデジタルにしているんですね
だから あの女の子たちが
あの薄い紙をね 水の上に入れて
もう 100円玉をね 真ん中に置いておいて待ってると
これちゃんと時計で計算できるでしょ？どれぐらい時間かかるかと
そうすると 1分で沈んだ女の子にあんた結婚できたのかとかね
どうすると まあそうなんです
半年以内に結婚できました
だから 1分以内で髪が落ちたら沈んだら
まあ半年で結婚できると計算してね
それから私の髪はもう 1 分 30 秒かかったというと
いつ結婚できる？はっきりするでしょうに
で そういうことで そこは私にとって
すごくかわいいこと アホなことやってるなとかね
だからなんだか人間がそこでなんとかデジタルにしちゃうんですね
だからみくじ引くでしょ
いらないよ あんなのは
神にちゃんと 100円あげて
じゃあ全ての幸せくださいとお祈りすればそれで OK なんですけど
やっぱり人間の脳がそれで納得いかないんですよ
脳がデジタルですからね
ですから また 100円入れてみくじを引いてみるんですね
そこはもう決まって もうあの凶と言うんですか
もうそういうくじはないんですね
あるのは小吉 吉 大吉 あれやこれやとかね
だから当たる確率はもうものすごく高いんで
そこはごまかしで 宗教の世界だからね
そこでもうくじを引いてみたら
まあ大吉とあってね あ
よかったと そこで自分が喜ぶんですよ
だから 脳にははっきりしたデジタル的なデータが欲しいんです
だから そういう宗教の世界ででも
そういう結構くだらないことをやっていて
私から見れば こういう完璧な嘘では商売にならないんだから
人間には微妙にでもデジタル的なとこを与えないと金くれないんですね
だからまあそうやってごちゃまぜでやってますね
しかし 宗教の世界はデジタル世界じゃなくて
完璧インチキ嘘の世界なんですね
大雑把なものは世の中で何もないんです
すべて精密に動いているんです
精密に 因果法則によって
地球の自転は大雑把じゃないんです
地球の公転は大雑把じゃないんです
太陽が何の制御もなく勝手に燃えているわけじゃないんです
すべてそれぞれの物理学法則によって
ぴったしデジタル的に動いているんです
私たちに計算できるかできないかは別な話で
いつでも十二信生の数字当てはめるわけじゃないんだからね
例えば心を制御する 心をコントロールするということは
私たちにはできることで
よくわかってますよ 時々友達が言ったことには気分が悪くなっちゃったんだけど
こらえてニコッと笑ってあげたりもします
その時制御しているでしょうに
だからできると経験あるんだけど
そこにはもう数字が当てはめることはちょっと難しいんですね
あんた何パーセントを制御したんですか？と言っちゃっても
それはちょっとわからないんですね
ただ それだけで数字デジタルを当てることはできる
できない場合はあるんだけど
本来はすべてデジタルで動いているんです
すべて 髪の毛が白くなったりするでしょうに
あるいは男性の場合 落ちたりもするでしょうに
ちゃんとした法則がありますよ
ちゃんとデジタル的にしっかりと落ちる時は落ちるんです
前もって落ちることはないんです
お祈りするんだからといって
落ちてくる髪が止まるということもないんです
白くなっていく髪はまた元に戻るということはないんです
お祈りのおかげで すべてデジタルなんですね
それだけデジタル方式がわかったならば
なんとかごまかしはできますね
例えば どういうことで髪の毛が落ちるのかと明確にわかったら
そこはある程度でコントロールできます
ある程度で そのある程度でコントロールできたら
ある程度で髪の毛が逃げてしまうことはちょっと時間が遅くなったりする
そういう風に人生すべてデジタルで見た方がよろしいんじゃないかなと思いますよ
結構楽ですよ 本当は迷信に足や足が引っ張られているよりは
しかし うまく機能するという自信はありませんね
制御できるんだけど 自信がないんですよ
思考は主観的で客観的にならない
このうまくいかない理由は
我々は勝手なこと 現実と関係ないくだらんことを考えているんですね
主観的にわがまま好き勝手で
わがまま好き勝手で妄想したっても
世界はそうじゃないんだから
デジタルだからね 私はポルシェ車欲しいなとね
思うのは勝手ですけど
店に行って買おうとするとデジタル世界なんです
金持っているのかと 分割で払いますけど
僕はデジタル的に調べるんですね
払えるかとないかと そこをデジタル的な条件が揃ったら
もう何のこともなく買えます
あまり大きな問題じゃないんですね
だから人間がその現実に当てはめることは考えないで
妄想だけする 主観で で
客観的に思考しない だから心の制御はうまくいかない
その分不幸になってしまいます
感情が割り込んできて
正しい思考に邪魔をする
それから怒り 嫉妬 憎しみが割り込んできて
正しく妄想ではなくて思考しているんですよ
考えているんですよ 考えてやっても
感情が割り込んじゃったら
全部ごちゃごちゃにハチャメチャになってしまいますね
期待する結果は得られません
だから我々には期待希望はありますよ
得られないんです だから仏教でも期待するものは得られないということは
人間にとって苦しみですよと説かれてますけど
それは暗い話じゃなくて
デジタル的な話なんです
うん ちょっと待って はい
次のスライドに行きます
今 意識について喋りました
意識は制御できるんだけど
私たちはまだ免許取って
私たちはただ 意識制御の免許取ってないんですね
次 無意識というところに行きます
で サブコンシャス この無意識という言葉は仏教ではないんです
完全な心理学はあるにも関わらず
無意識という言葉がないんです
これは西洋で不完全な心理学の世界で作った単語なんです
だから まあ一応今日を使ってみます
理解しやすいんだからね
仏教の心理学では この無意識っていうものはないんで
心のどんなところにもアクセスできますと
アクセスできるならば
制御できるならば 無意識とは言えないんです
それから心もデジタルで 1次元で働くんです
心  2つ同時に働かないんです
命 2つ同時にあるっていう話になりますからね
我々の命  2つ同時にあるわけじゃないですよ
多重人格者たちも あれはたくさんの心を持ってるわけじゃなくて
入れ替えてるんですよ
一回一つの人格なんです
ただ 人格的に一本じゃないんだから
病気だ 多重人格者とかね
治療しなくてはいけないんだというだけで
で しかし 私たち誰でも多重人格なんです
これ 西洋心理学で言っているよりも
かなりの人格がたくさんあるんです
で その都度その都度一つの人格がロギになって機能するだけ
だから 自分がどれぐらい人格演じる可能性あるのかって
それはある程度で その人人に決まってありますから
その中で一つ選んで その人格で生きてみる
その時間切れたら別の人格に変えたりする
ですから 正常だと思っている方々は誰であっても多重人格なんです
はい とにかくサブコンシャスに行きましょう
人は無意識に管理されています
まあ今日は理論的にはもう全部もう結論ばっかり言います
私たちは意識は制御しますけど
無意識に管理されているんです
無意識が主導権を取っているので
意識的に計画的に生きようとしても失敗します
だから人生の主導権を取っているのは無意識なんですね
だから幸福に生きようと思ったっても失敗します
司令官は別ですからね
無意識ですから しかし
無意識にアクセスできます
だから無意識に言えば簡単でしょ
無意識に言う 私は幸せになりたいんだからね
なんとかお願いしますと
そうすると無意識が じゃあわかりました
幸せになるように命令しますと言ったら
幸せになるはずなんです
でも 私たちの問題は無意識にアクセスできません
立ち入り禁止状態なんです
人の性格 運命 幸福 成功
失敗 努力できる範囲などは残念ながら無意識の管轄です
このまま覚えておいてください
人にいろいろ性格があるでしょ
あれは無意識なんです
だから性格は変えられませんね
変えたいんだけど変えられないんです
親がいくら言ってもね
親の気持ちわかりますよ
意識では わかるんだけど
自分の性格は変えられないんです
なんで変えられないかというと
性格が無意識の管轄なんです
それからみんなこの運命
運命という言葉を使っているでしょ
なんで運命という言葉
あれ 理知的的な単語じゃないんですね
ああ 運がなかったとかね
だから仏教では運命という言葉を使わないんです
お釈迦様は 使ったらこれは邪教やと言うんです
あなたの運が悪いとかね
あなたの運がいいとかね
これは使いません それは邪教です
私たちは運命というのは自分ではよくわからないんだけど
なんかいろんなものが起こるんですね
例えば やっと結婚したんだけど
1年  2年でもうそこはもう終わってしまう
それでまたもう不幸で不幸で
また誰か見つかっちゃいますけど
これも同じことになっちゃうんですね
また1年 2年しか持たなくなっちゃう
そうすると その人がやっぱり私には幸せな結婚
運命はないんだと 運がないんだと言っちゃうんです
なんか祈祷でもしてもらわなきゃ
お祓いでもしてもらわなきゃということになっちゃうんです
そこで宗教は商売やってますからね
家庭円満とかね 縁に恵まれるようにとか
商売やってますね で そちらに行ったりするんです
そこでお釈迦様の教えから見ればそうじゃなくて
これ自分の無意識なんです
無意識がそう決めてるんです
だから あの無意識がそのままだったら
この1年 2年で結婚失敗した人は4回結婚したっても同じことになっちゃうんです
それで人間が正しいデジタル思考ないんだから
やっぱりこれはあなたの運命で
あなた4回も結婚したでしょ
また4回目離婚したでしょ
だからあなたは結婚に向いてないと言っちゃうんです
何かもうご先祖様の怨念でもあるんじゃないんですか？とかね
いろんなことを言っちゃう
あれは一つの理屈的な説明ではないんです
だから私にも同じ相談をしたら
みんな怒って帰りますけど
私は理知的にも意識を見てね
問題言ってあげるんですね
あんたこれ直してよと
すると いい 私が結婚したいんだから
どうやって相手見つかるものかと聞いたのに
なんか関係ないこと言ってるんだと
と怒って帰るんですよ
そうじゃなくて 素直に私が言ったことやったら
大体半年以内で結婚できるんです
私は無意識を見て なんでこの女の子に相手見つからないのかと見たら
無意識のところでそのプログラム見えてくるんですね
そこを直す方法を教えてあげるんです
いや 出てこないんですね
はい そういうことで 運命っていうのは運命がないんですよ
あれは無意識の働きなんですね
そこで普通 我々は仕事をするでしょう
勉強もするでしょう 成功率は各人によって違うんですね
だから皆様も自分の人生を考えてみれば
どれぐらい成功しているか
どれぐらい失敗しているかという
なんとなく割り当てがあるんですよ
割合が これ変わらないんですね
ずっと そうすると運命やと思っちゃうんです
違います あれ 無意識のプログラムなんです
そこで努力したら結果出るっていうのは
あれは嘘です 努力しても努力したら
デジタルで努力したら結果が出ますよ
これはもうどうにもならん
しかし 努力するのは人間でしょ
機械じゃないんだからね
まあ例えば試験には 3ヶ月間あるし
勉強する量はこれぐらいあるし
デジタルで計算すれば 1 日もうもう 4時間 5
時間ぐらい勉強した方がよろしいと
そうすると試験にぴったし間に合いますよで計算できます
問題はそうじゃないんです
今日では 5時間勉強してやろうと思っても
3時間で終わっちゃうんです
もうこれ以上できないってことになっちゃうんです
頭でわかっていても そうすると
じゃあ明日もう今日の明日の 5時間分と今日の 2時間分させて 7
時間勉強してやると決めちゃうでしょ
あれ 計算違いんです なぜかというと
今日もできたのは 3時間だからね
明日もできるの 3時間だけなんです
5時間できない人はどうやって 7時間勉強するんだと 5
時間さえもできないくせに
だからそういう風に考えると
すごい人生楽なんですよ
こんな悔しくなって落ち込んだら
必要ないんです そういうわけで
私たちは努力すればぴったし答えが出ます
問題ないんです 例えば車が 80 キロで動かしちゃうと
この時間であの場所に行けるということは計算できますよ
だからといって必ずしも 80 キロで定速で行けるかというと
これに違うでしょ だからデジタル的に計算すると
80 キロで定速運転すれば 2時間 10分で行けると思っても
実際やってみるとそうにはそうはならないんですね
じゃあ 運転は客観的なものだから
まああまり問題はありません
しかし 私がということになってくると
努力するのは私なんですね
デジタルでこれぐらい努力しなさいとありますけど
やってみるとそこまでできる場合もあるし
また面白くてもっとできる人もいるんですよ
勉強する能力は 2時間あれば十分なのに
4時間も勉強できる人がいるんですよ
しかし そういう人々はその分すごくうまくいきますよ
私も覚えてますよ 小さい頃ね
1年の学校のテキストありますね
1年分の 私はそれもうもう 1ヶ月ぐらい以内で一人で勉強して
全部宿題も全部書いて
全部理解して終わっちゃった時もあります
他の学校のやり方 遅くて遅くてもう気に入らない
で そうなってくると まあ試験は問題ないし
まあ先生は絶対心配しないし
もう授業中ふざけたっても怒られませんしね
だってあんた何やってるの？って質問しませんだから
私 答え出しますからね
それで私は暗記するのはそれほど上手じゃないんですね
で 私が行った学校でも
いろんなものを一応暗記しなくちゃいけないと
古い文書とかね 古い人間書いた歌とかね
詩とかね それは暗記しなくちゃいかん
暗記しなきゃ勉強できる
難しいんですね 暗記は下手なんですね
そこで他の学問では 私はもう全部 1年分やってますから
先生たち知ってるんですね
そうすると一番下手な人から始めて
じゃああんたはい 次の日はい次
はい次とかね そこで暗記してないんだから
怒ったり怒鳴ったり あれやこれやで結構時間かかるんですよ
私は最後だからね それで 15人ぐらい
自分暗記していることはやってやって
間違い直して 発音を直して
私聞いてるでしょ もうぴったし暗記してるんです
自動的に そこで最後に
じゃあみんなに模範的に
まあこいつの暗記を聞いてみてくださいと
私の名前 じゃあ言いなさいと
一応私は完璧にもう先生びっくりするほど正しいイントネーションで
正しい発音で どこにも間違いなく暗記でもう言うんです
それで授業終わりますけどもね
私やってるのはすごい詐欺なんですけどもね
本当に全然暗記してなかったんです
だからそこをもうね 私が心理学知らなかった時期でも何やっていたかというと
自分が自分の無意識の能力を知っているんだから
これどうやってうまく制御するのかと
だから今日のセクション
暗記した人々は誰ですか？手挙げて下さいと言ったら
私は手を挙げますよ 知っていても手を挙げたっても嘘だなと
もしじゃああんたと言ったらダメになっちゃうし
バレちゃうしね  それでもかなり自信満々で手を挙げるんで
自信満々に手を挙げると
半分手を挙げる人から聞くんですね
先生 だからそこを計算して
まあとにかくその授業もうまく無事もう完了しちゃうというね
はい そこでこの努力の結果もではなくて
努力の程度  100%努力してするのはデジタル的な世界なんですけど
生の人間にはどんなパーセントかということは人によって違います
その分 幸福程度 成功率が変わっていくんです
そちら神様の関与はないんです
ご先祖様も何もやってないんです
関係ない人に文句言ってはいけませんよ
はい 私は残念ながらと入れたんですけど
それは私のまあ 蛇足で
やっぱりアクセスできないんだからね
感情を作って理性を壊すのも無意識です
次に一番悪いこと 感情を作るんですよ
無意識が だって怒ったりすると理由がないでしょ
嫉妬したりしたっても
何の理由もなくただ嫉妬しちゃう
人のことを嫌いになっちゃうと理由がないんですよ
ただ嫌い それだけなんです
だから理由がなければデジタル化できなかったら無意識なんです
あなたはうるさいんだから
あなたのことを嫌いと言ったら意識なんですね
デジタルなんですね すると相手がはい
わかりました 今日からうるさくしない
しないように頑張りますと言ったら
嫌いっていうことも消えちゃうんです
しかし 私たちの場合 そうじゃないでしょ
嫌いな人はいつたっても嫌いなんですよ
いいことをしても 悪いことをしても嫌いなんです
どうにもならんですよ
デジタルにならない だからそこも無意識なんですね
それで感情が作って出すことで
意識まで感情に感染するんですね
これ一番危険なのはそれなんです
はっきり言えば 我々の無意識が私たちの敵のように仕事をしているんです
仇敵なんですね あまりにも勝手で
で コントロールできないんですね
はい これからこの時間ないんだから
もう対策 いわゆる直す方法に行きます
そういうわけで 皆様方は意識についてそんなに困らなくてもいいんです
意識の制御できなかったら
親の言うことを聞けば
会社で上司の言うことを聞けば
それで OK です  普通の世の中にある決まり守ればいいんです
そんなに困らなくても大丈夫です
で  いたって簡単 しかし
無意識なんですね 問題は
まず無意識を発見します
皆 自分の性格をある程度で知ってますね
これよくデジタルで考えてください
私の性格ってどんなものかと覚えているはずなんですよ
小学校の時どうでしたかと
幼稚園の時どんなものでしたかと
小学校の時どんな子供でしたかと
高校生ではどんなことをやったのかとか
自分のことをちょっと調べてください
ごまかし 騙しをやめて
自分の性格とはいかがなものかと正直に自己分析してみるんです
そこで自分を騙してはならない
嘘はいかん もう幼稚園の時もものすごくはちゃめちゃ恥ずかしいことを
ばっかしやったならば
そのままチェックしておいてください
ごまかそうとしない 小学校の時は成績がもう最低でしたら構わない
そのままよろしいんです
見栄を張ってはならない
自分の性格をずっと調べてチェック入れておく
そのまま だからごまかしはダメ
騙しはダメ 次 感情の働き
感情の波 それから感情の種類
それから頻度 をチェックするんです
ブッダの教えがデジタルだからね
この通りにやらないとダメです
結構頭よくなりますよ
この感情の動きっていうのは
誰にだって感情がありますよ
気分が悪くなったり 気持ちが良くなったり
楽しくなったり 悲しくなったり
落ち込んだり 怒ったり
理由がなくても何でもぶつけたくなったりとかね
いろいろありますよ お腹が全然空いていないのに
パクパク食いたくなったり
お腹が空いているのに食べる気がなくなったりとか
いろいろありますよ すべて感情なんです
そこをチェックしてほしいんです
ここで難しい世界だから
仏教は助けてあげます
感情はカテゴライズしてありますね
仏教では 大体皆様知っている貪瞋痴ですね
貪瞋痴のたくさんのバージョンがあります
何かやる気がなくなっちゃうと
無知と怒りが割り込んでいるし
元気になった瞬間で欲が働いているし
まあだから専門用語でチェックすることもできるし
専門用語がなくても自分なりのラベルでよろしいんです
今は落ち込み中とかね
今は興奮中とかね 今イライラ中やとかね
そういう風に自分なりに自分の感情の動きをチェックして
それから感情の波あります
よくイライラするんだけど
そちらにも強弱がありましてね
今 私のイライラ度はかなり高いと
今イライラ度はちょっと弱いと
今 私の怒りがね 結構高いと
今怒っているんだけど
それほど高くないんだと
この波もチェックしてみる
それから種類ですね いろんな種類の感情があります
それもチェックする それから頻度も大事なんです
頻度はとても大事なんです
なぜかというと この頻度で自分の性格が見えますから
例えば怒る頻度が高いんだったら
もう怒りに対する治療をしなくちゃいけない
欲張ってはちゃめちゃ失敗する頻度が高いんだったら
そちらの治療をしなくちゃいけない
スケベでいつでも異性のことばっかし追っかけているんだったら
そこは自分の感情の頻度が高いところなんですね
スケベの方々はだいたい怒りがないんですよ
いつでもニコニコと笑って
かっこつけて誰か相手にちょっかい出したいんですね
だから怒ったらダメだから
その方々は怒らないんですね
そういうことだから もうこの種類ですね
その場合は 種類で頻度が高いものはだいたい自分の性格なんですね
そこで治療する場合はそちらに治療するんです
しかし また注意があります
しかし 批評はしない そのまんま
いい悪はどうでもいいんです
私はこういうものであると自分でチェックする
悪いものやとか 良い人やとかとりダメです
そうすると科学的でなくなっちゃうんです
批評しません それから無理に直そうともしない
それはいりません 例えば
飼っている猫がかわいいかもしれませんだけど
猫と一緒に猫に散歩をさせるということはありえないでしょ
これ直せないんですよ
だから皆様 猫を飼っているならば
家の中でもう勝手に自由に生活するようにしてあげてください
しかし 犬を飼ったならば
また話が別 犬も猫と一緒にいればいいんじゃないかなと思っても
犬にとっては散歩してもらわないと
だから直す必要ないんです
必要ないではなくて そこももう置いといて
そのまま性格を理解するんです
それで私たちはすごいことをやったことになるんです
自分を支配している 自分を管理している
自分を指導している 自分の人生をハチャメチャにしている
この恐ろしい無意識を発見したんです
見つけたんですよ ただ発見するだけです
はい 次治療に入ります
無意識の掃除 無意識を見ると無駄な妄想がいっぱいで
心のエネルギーを浪費させていることは発見するはずです
だから 怒りの頻度が高い人に怒りを直すことじゃないんです
もうスケベでどうにもならん人だっても
それ直そうとしないんです
このブッダの治療方法では
このどんな病気であろうとも
基本的な原因があるんです
妄想 妄想がその病気を作っているんです
だから スケベの病気に治療しないで妄想に治療するんです
怒りに固まって もうどうにもならん人の怒りに治療しない
妄想に治療するんです
そこで自分の無意識を発見すると
誰だって自分たちは頭いっぱい妄想しているということを発見するんですね
この妄想すると 生きるエネルギーが全部浪費するんだと
とわかるんです だから誰だって元気じゃないんです
クタクタ疲れているんです
あの生命力はどこへ行ったかというと
妄想に浪費させているんです
あまりもスピードで我々はアイドリングしているんです
だから車が壊れるんです
激しいアイドリングなんです
妄想は必ずと言えるほど感情で汚れています
妄想がなんで取り留めもないように出てくるかというと
妄想と恐ろしい感情が一緒になっているんです
欲 嫉妬 落ち込み 高慢 自我などの感情
たくさんありますからね
感情は生きることを不幸の連続にしてしまいます
私たちの敵は感情なんです
幸福にならないのは 神のお怒りではなくて
あなたの感情ですということで
全然幸福 幸福にならない
不幸の連続 そこで 感情がいつでも妄想に乗ってるんで
妄想が乗り物 妄想がなかったら感情にはどうしようもなくなっちゃうんですね
だから妄想っていうのは言語で言葉でやってますから
いくらでも回転できますね
そうすると感情にはいつだって乗り物があるんだから
乗るは乗るは乗るは 乗る乗るたびにこれがもう繁殖するんです
増えるんです 自己破壊するまで
さらに生きる力がなくなるんですね
だからどんどん生きる力がなくなっていくんです
掃除する必要があります
性格掃除するんじゃなくて
妄想掃除するんです はい
掃除の仕方 無意識の掃除ですね
置き換える訓練 どうしても妄想しちゃうんだから
もう慣れてるんだから
じゃあ置き換えるしかないんです
ただ 妄想のテーマを変えて
意図的に妄想させるんです
今自分が妄想してるでしょ？あのテーマ変えるんです
別なテーマにするんです
別なテーマを妄想するんです
意図的にわざわざと この意図的にということもすごい大事な言葉なんです
あとで説明します 治療の効果があるテーマを必ず選ぶんです
だから治療機能のあるテーマでなければ
別に病気になるテーマにしたらもう話にならんでしょ
今も病気で 別に別な病気を移してもらいましょうと
これはちょっとまずいんですね
病気が増えただけで 肺炎が嫌な人は肺がんになってもらうとかね
肺がんになったら肺炎はそれほど苦しくないんだけどね
でもダメでしょ だから妄想は置き換えますけど
治療的なテーマにしなくちゃいけない
そこでどんなテーマが治療的になるのかっていうことは
これはお釈迦様にしか言えないんです
正統学者であるブッダは精密にデータを選ばれたので問題ありません
学校の先生に聞いても
親に聞いても 頭良くなる妄想を教えてくれません
ないんです それから自己啓発本とかあるでしょ
あれってさらに病気にするだけ
欲をさらに 病気にするだけで意味がないんです
精密に心の働きを調べてテーマを選ばなくちゃいけない
それはお釈迦様が完全たる心理学者でしたから
すべて完了したんだから
データを全部遠慮なく出してます
はい こういうテーマなんですね
一部入れました 慈悲喜捨
皆様知ってる単語ですね
慈随観 苦随観 無常随観
無我随念 念仏 念処 念処
順番間違ってますね で
戒随念 不浄随念などなど
こういうテーマで まあはっきり言えば妄想してくださいと
例えば慈悲喜捨の慈あるでしょ
それはメッターなんですね
で フレーズで言えば 生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
これを覚えて ハチャメチャ妄想すればいいんです
うまくいきます しかし
テーマが違いますね ああ
あの人はなんかなんか困ってる顔をして
まあまあ幸せだった方がいいなとかね
このアリさんが餌を探してるみたいなぁ
アリさんにも餌が見つけたら幸せでしょうねとかね
動物は餌に喧嘩していると
餌 餌いっぱいあった方がね
喧嘩しないで仲良くできますねとかね
そういう風にいろんなことを妄想するんです
しかし 自分のテーマは慈しみなんです
あいつをぶん殴らなくちゃとは思わないんです
動物二人が喧嘩している餌に
そこで弱い動物の餌を奪われたと
普通の人はあのカラスはね
追い出さなくちゃとかねと怒っちゃうでしょ
それダメですよ ではなくて
慈しみ 弱い鳥さんにもね
何か餌があった方がいいなとかね
そういう風に自分が選んだテーマに合わせて妄想してみる
この慈悲 悲っていうのは苦しみがなくなりますようにってことですね
そう見てみると 結構人間も生命もあらゆる問題を抱えているんですね
それは苦しみなんですよ
動物に至っても餌は見つからないし
縄張りがあって 自分の縄張りの中で十分餌がないし
交尾しなくちゃいけないんだけど
その場合でも喧嘩しなくちゃいけないし
いろいろ大変でしょう
で 水の中に生活しているんだからといってね
魚たちに人生は楽じゃないんですよ
いつ誰かに殺されるかわからないんで
とても危険な環境なんですよ
水の中っていうのはものすごい危険なんです
人間にしたっても同じことで
いろいろトラブルの中で生きているんですね
そうすると 私 悲を決めた人がね
みんなトラブルがなく
苦しみがなくいた方がいいなとかね
この人は仕事で苦しんでますけど
仕事の能力が上がってね
楽々になった方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
あの人と上司がね ちょっと性格が合わなくて困ってるみたいだなとかね
もうちょっとこの二人が仲良くした方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
そういう風に妄想してみるんです
喜っていうのは喜びですね
それは至って簡単ですね
自分のことを見ると 自分が結構幸せでいるんですね
自分が過ぎているところをチェックする
これが空いてる これが空いてる
これが空いてる ああ それなのに私は幸せやと
他の人々を見ると また見つかるんですね
みんな空いてるところ
あの人は結構いい服を着てるんだとかね
あの人の体のプロポーションが結構かっこいいなとかね
ああ よかったねとかね
そのようにいろんな生命を見ると
みんなに空いてるところ見えてくる
そうすると ああ よかったよかったって自分が喜びを感じる
そういう風に一応妄想してみるんです
はい 次は知識系の性格が知識的である人々をね
にあるテーマなんですね
この慈 思惟念というのはね
というのは 死っていうのは物事は壊れるということですね
命がなくなるんですね
どういうふうに頑張っても
どんな命でもなくなりますよと
誰の命でも短いんだよと
この短い間で もうなんとか頑張るしかないんだと
長く計画を立てたっても
それはそうならないでしょうとかね
百年計画 百年計画はならないでしょうと
せいて一日計画だったらいいんじゃないかなとかね
明日生きてられるかわからないんだと
ですから 人間っていうのは一日計画で生きていった方が楽じゃないかなとかね
私も 1日計画で生きてみようではないかとかね
そのように必ず生命が死ぬんだという現実
事実をテーマにして それに関わることを考えてみる
わかりやすいが 妄想してみる
なんで妄想してみると言ったかというと
考えたっても実行できるかできないかわからないでしょ
上司とも性格合わなくて毎日苦しんでいる人の場合は
上司ももっと親切になった方がいいなとかね
この人ももうちょっと能力が上げて
上司と仲良くできるようにした方がいいんじゃないかなと思っても
自分にとって関係ないんだからね
実行できないでしょ だから私は妄想という言葉を使ったんです
妄想してくださいと この無常随観も知識系の人々にできて
世の中を見てみるとすべて無常なんですね
無常で成り立っている
無常だから成り立っている
このマイクロフォンは無常で壊れるんだから
マイクロフォンとして仕事をしているんです
この照明はどんどん衰えて壊れるんですよ
だから光出してるんです
無常だから流せているんです
すべて そういうことで
ちょっと理性があって
頭がいい人にとっては
世の中は無常で見ることができます
無我随念 で 無我っていうのは自我の反対なんですね
我々は結構自我張ってますよ
しかし 頭がちょっと良い頭があったら自我張れないんだとわかりますよ
すべてお互いの合意の上で成り立っているんです
話し合いなんですよ 自我じゃないんです
計画世界なんです あるレストランで美味しいご飯があるんだからってくれるわけないんです
自我を張ってこれ出しなさいと言ったって
それはダメですね 決まりがあるんです
それで自分が食べたい美味しいものは食べられます
だから理性で見ると 自我は張れないものなんです
お母さんに車買いたいんだから金くれと言ったっても
はい 持って行ってくださいとはないんです
そこであらゆる話し合いがあって
合意したところでの結果だけなんです
自分が全額もらえたんだけどね
それはないでしょう もしかすると
最初に払うお金ぐらいはくれるかもしれません
それから自分がバイトして
もう分割を払わなくちゃいけないと
合意なんですね だから無我随念というのは
そのように自我が成り立たない
6時間もブッ素つけて勉強したいと思っても成り立たない
この本の内容は 1発で覚えたいなっていうのは自我なんですけど
成り立たない それも合意なんです
自分の脳細胞と 自分の脳と話し合ってみなきゃ
そこで話し合ってみたら
見ると ある程度の合意に達する
その分はうまくいくだけなんです
そういうわけで 無我随念というのは
この自我は張れないものであると
自我張ったら一つも動いていかないものであると
自我はないんだと 世の中を見ると
デジタルで見ると 宗教を捨ててみると
霊魂なんかないんだと見えてくるんです
魂なんかないんだと見えてくるんです
すべて話し合いであって
合意であって じゃあ自分の体どうですかね
私も年を取りたくはないんですよ
私の自我なんですけど
でも自我張っても年取っちゃいますからね
どうにもならん 私も病気にはなりたくない
そんなことを思ったってもなりますね
そのように無我随念 念仏っていうのは
お釈迦様のこと 正覚者の能力を勉強することなんです
もうこじが抜けるほどすごいたくさんあります
2番目 次は念法なんですけど
ブッダが直々教えたものを学んでみるんです
念相っていうのは聖者たちのことなんですね
サーリプッタ モッガラーナなどなどのね
大阿羅漢たち ものすごい偉大なる人々なんですよ
人生を見てみると感動するんです
なんて素晴らしい方でしょうと
そういうことを勉強してみるんです
戒随念というのは道徳ですね
まあ自分が何かしらいろいろ道徳を守っているんだから
まあそこら辺はよく観察して
私はこういうこういう道徳を持っていて
こういう生き方を持っている人間であると
それを大事に重んじてみること
不浄随念というのは まあ要は説明を
まあ肉体は不浄であると見ることなんですね
そのテーマの中で一つ選んで
たくさん選ばなくてもいいんです
一つ選んで妄想してみるんです
妄想して自己破壊的な妄想を置き換えるんです
今ずっと取り留めもない妄想しています
あれは自己破壊 これで新たなテーマを入れて同じ妄想するんです
それで自己破壊的な妄想が自分を幸福にしてくれる妄想に変換しているんです
それで無意識が治るんです
スケベの場合はスケベ病が治るんです
怒り 怒りっぱなしの人の怒り病が治るんです
怠け病の人の怠けが治るんです
これで意図的に行うということをね
自動的にできないんです
無明 存在欲と怯えに無意識が抑えられているので
自然に上の実践はできません
覚えておいてください
素直に自然にできると思ったら
それは違うんです 我々の無意識も怯え
怯えているんです 存在欲があるんです
怯えがあるんです 無明なんです
だから新しいテーマを教えてあげても難しいんですよ
慈悲の妄想はしたいんだけど
なかなかできないんですよ
だから意図的に 無理やりに始めなくちゃあかんのです
努力して意図的に訓練するんです
実践の仕方は 自分が選んだテーマに関する短いフレーズを繰り返し念じること
一番最初にできることが
例えば生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと覚えておく
覚えてそれに念じる 一番最初にやりやすい方法はそれなんです
あるいは 私はとても幸せで生きている
他の人々のことを見たら
みんなそれぞれ自分の幸せを見つけて幸せで生きている
ああ よかったと そういうふうにフレーズ一つを覚えて念じるんです
このフレーズもブッダではちゃんと
この瞑想にはこのフレーズ
この瞑想にはこのフレーズとありますけどね
もうパーリ語ですからね
日本語に翻訳するとちょっと面倒くさくはなります
例えば慈 施 ヴィパッサナーの場合は
生きるものには死が確実
というフレーズ 死を目指して生きる
生命は死を目指して生きるというか
向かって生きる 目指してないんだから向かって生きる
死を向かって生きる これをずっと繰り返すんです
頭の中で 生命は死を向かって生きる
生命は死を向かって生きている
私も死を向かって生きている
これは実践のレッスン1なんです
これ 無理にやらなくちゃダメでしょ
で 無理にやると慣れてきます
妄想ができなくなった心が治り始めます
これ念じると妄想の暇がないでしょ
それで心が自動的に治っていくんです
だから余計に治そうとするのは余計余計なんです
自動的に治ります このシステムやれば
最初は苦しく感じても
すぐとても穏やかな仕事であると発見します
だから この実践を始めた人は
ちょっと苦しいな これはね
やりにくいなと感じるんですよ
感じてもやってみると心が治りますからね
心が治ってくると気分がいいんですよ
ああ 気持ちいいんだ ああ
穏やかだと そうすると自然にできるようになってくるんです
次のステップは再発防止
で 心直ったのはいいんだけど
再発したらどうしますかね
再発防止やります 心が治っても
まだ再発 再発する恐れが大いにあります
次のステップとして 自分が念じる言葉の意味を観察します
まずはちゃめちゃ幸せでありますように
幸せでありますように
もう生きるものは死を向かって生きている
すべての生命は死へ向かって生きていると念じるんだけど
もうどんどんそれできるようになってきたら
これはどんな意味かと観察するんです
観察すると再発防止になるんです
その見解を用いて生きてみることにも挑戦する
念じるだけじゃなくて
例えば慈悲だったら 仕事をする時でも
慈悲の気持ちで仕事をしてみる
料理を作る時でも 慈悲の気持ちではみんな美味しく食べて幸せになってほしいとかね
公園でゴミを見つけたら
あ これはみんなに気持ち悪いんだから
私はこれ拾ってゴミ箱に入れて
みんなにいい綺麗な環境を作ってあげますと
みんなそれで楽しくなるでしょうとか
ベンチが汚れていたら
見たらちょっときれいにしてあげたりして
そうすると子供たちでも誰でも鳥のフンがあったりするとね
それで何か持ってきて
それちょっときれいにしてあげて
で みんな気持ちよく座ってるでしょうね
これだったらと そうやって自分のテーマを日常生活で使ってみるんです
素晴らしい人間になるんです
もう再発防止です 心が治っただけじゃなくて
決して同じ病気が絶対再発しないということになるんです
理性が現れるので再発防止になります
なんで再発防止かというと
こんなことをやると 自分にはいまだかつてなかったある能力が出てくるんです
理性が出てくるんです
理性が必要だったら この無意識をくったくた踏みつけなくちゃかんです
で 踏みつくっていうことは良くない単語かもしれませんだけど
無意識をオーバーホールするんです
きれいに大掃除して ゴミ一欠片もないように大掃除して
正しい思考で置き換えていく
これはもうきれいさっぱりオーバーホールすることなんです
その時初めて理性っていうものが出てくるんです
理性の度合い によって
妄想の悪力がね 減ります
で まあこれは難しいかもしれませんだけど
妄想っていうのは悪い力を持ってます
破壊力を持ってますね
理性が現れると すぐ力がなくなります
緩和します はい もう無意識の管理ね
これは仏教でしか教えられませんだから
まあ最初に教えました
意識の管理 気にする必要ないと言いましたからね
まあそちらもちょっとアクセスしてみましょう
無意識を管理すると 意識が自動的に管理されます
困らなくてもいいんです
しかし あります よく学ぶこと
賢者と付き合ったり 話し合ったりすること
この頭のいい人 性格のいい人と仲良くして
強引でもいいんですよ
強引にでも仲良くする
して話したりする ブッダの教えを観察すること
でお釈迦様がおっしゃった教えをね
よく観察して調べてみる
本当かないかと それから理性のある人と対話すること
頭の優れた人々といろんなテーマで対話してみる
テーマはどうでもいいんだけど
理性のある人と対話すると
結構学ぶものが出てくるんです
結構出てきます そういうことで意識も育てます
学ぶときは必ず自分で納得するという反応が起きるまで努力するんです
これを覚えてください
学んだだけで全然ダメですよ
脳に何か反応がないと脳が変わらないとダメなんです
脳がどこが変わるかというと
納得したら変わるんですね
勉強していると 脳が納得という気持ちになったら
脳がもう変わっているんです
勉強もしているんです
勉強したことになるんです
納得しない限りは勉強ではなくて
ただデータを覚えただけ
それはすぐ消えます データは
だから学ぶときは納得するということは
皆様の人生のネックレスみたいな感じにしてください
バッジにしてください
何を 何をしよう 何をやろう
何を学ぼう まあ納得するようにしますと
すごい大事なポイントなんです
納得するとは なんか文章を間違えていますね
脳の発展です どんなつまらないものであっても
どんな小さなことであっても
納得したら脳がほんのちょっと成長したんです
納得と脳の成長なんです
これを覚えておいてください
だから 納得すればするほど
脳は成長します だからこの信仰でもって納得するとかね
あまりにも派手に強引に教えると
もう納得したような気分になる
あるでしょ あれは危険ですね
納得っていうのは自分で理解して納得するんです
じゃあ今日のスライドです
前のスライドですが 上から 3行目の賢者としかしよく学ぶこと
賢者との次ですが  ん？ しかしよく学ぶこと
賢者と 次の言葉ですが
付き合っている 付き合おうかとかですね
付き合うんですよ 恋愛関係じゃない
これは私も考えてこの感じにしたんですよ
だから恋愛だけじゃなくて
賢者のことを好きになるということは理性的なことなんですね
だから好きでも構わないんだけど
そうするといやいやでも付き合う羽目になっちゃうでしょ
で 私は自分の先生たちのことをすごく無理やりに義理で付き合ってないんです
やっぱり先生たちが教えてくれると好きになるんですよ
先生のファンになっちゃうんです
そうするとすごくそれスムーズに学べるんです
だから私もそこを考えて
やっぱりこの感じの方がいいなと
皆様方は恋愛関係にしていますけど
それに限ってないんだと覚えた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
どんな付き合いも付き合いになったら楽です
だから年寄りの面倒を見なくちゃいけないと思って
無理やりに面倒見るでしょ
付き合いするでしょ やっぱりストレス溜まっちゃうんですよ
それで 2日  3日と教えるの面倒を見ると
なんか自分にとって可愛い存在になってくるんですね
好きになるんですよ そうすると気持ち的にすごく楽
ありがとうございます
そういうことを考えて一応入れたんです
次次よろしいですか？また何か問題ある？うん
はい 次 大きなテーマ 希望
願望の管理 一般的な希望
願望は心のガンです しかし
希望 計画 期待などの何かがないと活動できないということも事実です
本当は心のガンなんですよ
希望は 願望は こんなこと言われて何か希望がないと生きていられないでしょう
努力できないでしょ なんかハメられてます
何か目的がない 何か希望がないと
存在欲と怯えから現れるすべての希望
願望 願い 期待 企画などは心のガンであると理解しましょう
一応理解しましょう 生き物は存在欲で生きているんです
存在欲は成り立たないんだから怯えているんです
そこで存在欲と怯えから期待
願望が現れてくるんです
それで自己破壊になっちゃうんです
私たちも同じで企画作るでしょ
あれは生きるためなんです
あるいは怯えをなくすためなんです
心配をなくすためなんです
まず そこを理解してほしい
ごまかしダメですよ ごまかしダメ
期待なくしなさいとは言ってないんです
だって 期待何かなければ生きていられないんだからね
ただ 騙す 騙されてはいけません
これは心のガンだと覚えてほしい
意識しなどの清らかな気持ちから起こる希望などは
心のガンになりません
解決はあります もう妄想入れ替えたでしょ
妄想入れ替えて訓練したでしょ
それから生活にも当てはめたでしょ
そうすると新たな希望
願望 企画いっぱい出てくるんです
それは存在欲から出ていないんです
みんなやっぱり幸せであった方がいいなっていうのはね
自分の存在欲じゃないんです
試験に 試験勉強している子供たち
みんな合格してほしいなというのはね
自分にとっては全然関係もないんです
だから 前に私が説明したプラクティス
実践をやってみると 今までやったがんの希望が消えるんです
消えて別な希望が生まれるんです
別な期待が生まれるんです
別な企画が生まれてくるんです
そうすると副作用も何もないんだから
いくらでも頑張れるんです
会社を発展する企画書かもしれませんよ
今まで儲かる目的で 自分を売り込む目的で
ライバル会社を潰す目的で作ったんだから
自分が自己破壊しているんです
今度はそうじゃなくて
会社が繁栄するべき 会社が繁栄すると
社員たちはみんな安定して生きている
生きては生きられる それで
この会社の品物で他の人々もすごく助かっている
だったら私は新しい企画を作って
より一層みんな幸せになる風にしなくちゃあかんと思ったら
いくらでもエネルギーが生まれてくるんです
2日  3日徹夜していても全然疲れません
そういうことで この心の中が変わるだけなんです
テーマまで変わるわけじゃないんです
普通の仕事をして 普通の勉強をして生活するんだけど
自分の期待 願望などは変わっちゃうんですね
普通に家族が幸せにしてあげたい
してあげたいと思って
あれやこれやと それ ちょっと変わるんですね
で みんなそれぞれ元気で明るくていてほしいなと思うと頑張れるんですね
ご飯食べてからみんな美味しい美味しいって言ってほしい
期待はダメなんです それは自分の存在欲なんですね
特にお母さんたちがね
ご飯作ってあげて あ 美味しかったという言葉が欲しがるんですね
で まあお母さんに美味しかったというのも悪くはないんだけど
ただ旦那に褒めて欲しくて家の仕事ばっかりやっちゃうと
なんか疲れちゃいます
ストレス溜まるんです
それで思考を変えて いえ
私はみんな何の文句も言わない
楽々に生きられる 自由に成長できる環境を作ってあげますと
言って頑張ると疲れませんし
ストレスもたまりませんし
もういくらでも頑張れるんですね
そういうことで 希望はがんですから
そのがん細胞ではなくて
死 正常な細胞にするんです
脳の中で そのために思考を着替えることはもう欠かせない訓練なんです
はい それでもう一つ微妙なテーマ違う
精神がん患者の症状 これ覚えておいてください
で 皆様にもあると思います
皆さんもがんあると思いますよ
願望のがん 希望のがん
だからがんかないか 症状がないと調べれませんからね
よく祈る お守り 札などに頼る
パワースポットを巡る
もうがんです これはネガティブフィードバックなんですね
カタカナで書こうと思ってもなかなか出てこなかったんです
私のカタカナ発音がもういまだにダメなんですね
わからないんだから ローマ字で書いたんですが
ネガティブフィードバックなんです
神社仏閣などなど 行っては祈る
行っては祈ると 祈るたびにネガティブフィードバックなんです
みんなわからない 心のからくりは
で 説明あります 仕事がうまくはかどれますようにと願う場合は
無意識で仕事はうまくいっていないという強い感情がフィードバックされます
あーなんとか神様 私の仕事がうまくいきますようにというと
本人の無意識が認めているんで
お前バカやと お前の仕事はうまくいかないんだよと
で 無意識が指導者でしょ
指導者にネガティブフィードバックしてどうするんですかね
だからみんなとても危険なことやってますよ
世の中でこの宗教狂いの世界は
とても危険ですよ 天にましますなんとか御用とかね
言ってはあかん 今日のお食事を与えてくれて感謝しますと
目の前で嘘でしょうに
ですから 例えば女の子たちに私よく言ったんですね
結婚したい 結婚したい
あんたね その気持ちやめてちょうだいと
あれ ネガティブフィードバックなんですよ
あー結婚したいなと思っちゃうと
相手がいない 私はあんまり
なんて言いますか モテないとかね
思ってるんですよ だからそう思うたびにさらにモテなくなっちゃうんだよ
だから私の若い女の子のアドバイスは
そんなこと忘れちゃえと
あんた みんなあんたって可愛いなというふうに思えるように
明るくニコニコと笑って
みんなさっさとお茶入れてあげるわとかね
で なんかみんな楽しくなるような言葉をかけてあげるわとかね
そういうふうに 普通に友達の間で雰囲気をきれいにすることだけ正直にやってくださいと
みんな喜んだらそれで十分やと
そうするとネガティブフィードバックにならないんです
ものすごく早く相手見つかるんです
それで男性の方の中でいきなりもう
あ この人やと と思っちゃって
カチーンと心がそこで繋がっちゃうんです
だから こんな心でいい加減に遊ぶことできません
お釈迦様に聞いてもらわないと
それで女性の方々 おしゃれしたりいろいろするでしょ
もう結婚適齢になっちゃって
とにかく誰か相手の人をつかまりたいで吸ったり釣りたいでしょ
で 逃げるんです 皆様にも苦い経験あると思いますけど
自分がすごい苦労して
服装を考えて 色を考えて
コーディネーション考えて
それに合わせてアクセサリー耳やら首を入れて
唇の色までずっと考えて苦労してくれるけど
みんな全然気づきもしないんです
それで勝手に腹が立ちますね
そうすると次はもっと派手にやっちゃいますね
そうすると可愛いところはちょっとどうこうしちゃって
ぐっずい気持ち悪いところになっちゃうんですね
これはネガティブフィードバックなんです
そういうふうにやってはいけません
お化粧するときは こういうところに行きますから
まあ普通に時々に溶けるような程度にしてあげますというと
相手のことをちゃんと大事に考えているんです
そうなってくると 何のことなく
ああ あんた今日は結構かわいいねとかおしゃれですねとか言ってくれます
雰囲気にぴったしはめる時は美しいんです
花と同じなんです ただ
花束を横に置いていたっても美しくないでしょ
そこを綺麗に雰囲気に合わせるんです
これはお化粧の意味数なんです
だから労働でね トラック運転したり
庭師になっている女の子たちもいるでしょ
そうするとお化粧とか何でも可愛いんですよ
あんなすごい汚い 汚いではない
作業服を着てね もうものすごい分厚い手袋をはめて
もう庭師やってる女の子もテレビで見たんですけど
結構可愛いと思ったんですね
頭のいい男だったら この女は逃がせませんよと
やっぱり美しさがいつだって消えるものじゃないんですよ
この雰囲気に合うか合わないかなんです
だから庭師の女の子がね
スカートを履いて口紅もつけてやっちゃうと最悪でしょ
だから作業服の間から
これは美しい女性であると見えますよ
これは隠せません だから皆様
結構無駄やってますね
本当にやり方知らないんだから
やっていること全部ネガティブフィードバックになっちゃうんですね
祈れば祈るほど期待外れの結果になります
あのお守りとかあちこちつけるのは構わないんだけど
あれはお遊びでおしゃれで
記念でであれば OK なんです
成田さんに言ったら せっかく行ったんだからね
何か何か買って あちらこちらぶら下がって持っていこうかなという遊びだったら
祈りが入ってないんですね
ですからネガティブフィードバックはないんです
そうすると良い結果になるのです
だから我々は希望 願望のがん患者であるかないかは
この症状でわかるんです
はい 次 ポジティブフィードバックに変えましょう
希望は ポジティブフィードバックというのは
私は努力しています 成功もしている
幸福に生きている 考えてみれば
大げさな問題ではありませんと
まあ私は私なりに頑張ってますよと
まあそれなりの仕事もありますし
まあ収入もそこそこうまくいってますよ
幸せよと そう思ってください
うまくいっているんだと
そんな大げさなことじゃないんだと
思考をすごく変えないとね
両親のことを考えてらいっぱい
何といいますか 幸せもんだと感じるはずなんですよ
だって他の両親がいないんだからね
だから私の両親は世界一だと
そう思わなきゃダメなんです
まあ誰だって親だからね
そんなのはまあ生物学的に産んだんだから育てただけでしょうと言っちゃうと
それはすごいネガティブ思考なんですね
産んだんだから育てたわけじゃないんですよ
やっぱり愛情を注いで育てるんですよ
それは遺伝子のからくりかもしれませんだけど
本人は遺伝子の存在を知らないんだからね
動物も子供産んだらもう命かけて守るんですよ
子供 あれは遺伝子のからくりですけど
知ってますかね 知らない
皆様のお母さんももう遺伝子のあれで必死で子育てしましたけど
やっぱりそれはわかりません
ただ 我が子のことは世界一かわいい
それだけ そういうことだから
まあ自分が本当に立派な親のところで生まれたんだと
立派に育てられましたと
そこを覚えてほしい  100万回の 1回だけ失敗して
それだけ覚えているでしょ
あの時 母親がものすごく反対しました
それだけ覚えているんです
もうあまりにも心が壊れているんですね
そういうわけで 私たちは友達もいるでしょ
友達もいることで 仕事もあることで
まあそれなりに借金しないで生活もできることで
幸せだ 幸せだとかね 結構恵まれているんだと
で この前 私は自分の国に国に帰って帰って昨日帰りましたけど
一回だけ説法したんですね
それも私をいじめる目的で
信者さんが説法を頼んだと思いますけど
突然お正月ですから 私は前もって連絡してあった
お正月には大法事やりますから
日にちを合わせて準備してくださいと言ったら
その日は休みがないんだから
31日 またそういう立場も休みじゃないんです
向こうは だからできませんって言ったらね
土曜日にしてくださいと
いて もう結構引っ張っちゃったんですね
26 7日に だからお正月気分じゃないしね
それで終わったんだけど
やっぱり31日になってきて
もうまた来て やっぱり何かもう一つ法やりましょうよと
普段やっている日常のね
私はまあいいですよと言って
そういう立ちの夜 法をやりました
その時説法しましたけどね
その時 今日のテーマの中に結構言いました
祈る 祈るなよと  向こうの連中に言うのは至って簡単ですからね
もう祈るのよ 祈っちゃったら逆になっちゃいますよと
勉強できますように 合格しますようにとか
勉強できますようにといったら勉強できないって意味でしょ
合格しますようにと言ったら合格する自信がないでしょ
で やめちゃえと やめて
あなた方は世界一恵まれているんだと
人間に生まれたことはどれほど徳だと思っているのかいと
あなた方はこの貧乏なスリランカで生まれたんだけど
同じチケットで天界の一番トップの天界にも生まれるチケットでしたよと
業から見れば だから天界でもどこでも生まれたいところで生まれるぐらいのバウチャーを持って
この国を選んでね 貧乏な国を選んでここで生まれたんだから
ものすごく恵まれているんだ
だからこちら選んだ理由があるんだよと
あんた方は他の国と違って
昔から参謀に帰依するブッダの教えを学ぶ国に生まれたんだ
いたって簡単に理解できるんだから
あの連中のブッダの教えはね
それで毎日何回も説法を聞くかというと
私は車で移動するんだから
ラジオをつけてますけどね
まあ説法は流れるは流れるはもうキリがないんです
チャネル変えて変えて説法を聞いてるんですよ
これでお坊さんたちも結構説法するのは上手ですから
他のプログラムよりは説法のプログラムが結構人気があるんです
だから日本と違うんですよ
それでお坊さんたちも誰よりも完璧に言葉使う
発音がもう完璧 間違いも一つもない
文法は文章すべてぴったし
しかし 誰にでもわかるように理解できる
また語る だったら子供でも聞くんですよ
そうするともう国語ぐらいでもよくなりますから
はい そういうことで 私はあの人に言ったのは
あなた方はね もうはちゃめちゃ恵まれて恵まれすぎだと
そこを確認しなさいよと
だからフレーズを作ったんですね
我々は崖から落ちたっても
かすり傷 かすり傷 かすり傷もつかない人間だよと
頑丈だと そういうふうに思ってくださいと
誰かが崖から蹴っ飛ばしても
蹴っ飛ばされても かすり傷もないと
そこまで恵まれてますよと
それを確認しなさいと
それがポジティブフィードバックの方なんです
しかし 人は成長するべきなので
さらにうまくいきますようにと努力する
今はものすごく恵まれてるんだけど
やっぱり人間というのは成長しなきゃいけないだからね
まあだからここで止まることをしないで
もうちょっと頑張ってみましょうと
あれは何もないからじゃなくて
不幸だからじゃないんです
もっと仕事の能力を上げるのは
高い給料が欲しいんだからじゃなくて
今の給料でも生きていられる
でも このままでいるのは
なんかちょっと人間として情けない
だから能力を上げます
能力上げたら給料も上がるかもしれませんだけど
それはそんなに大きな問題にしない
そういうわけで 毎日も頑張ってみる
今も一歩一歩進んでいるので
止まることなくさらに進むというやり方です
これがポジティブフィードバックですね
だから祈りをやめてこれやってください
幸せになりたければ 幸福でありますようにではなくて
私はすごく幸福なものやと
というふうに変えるんです
慈悲の瞑想について私はちょっと今もちょっと考えたんですけど
皆様に教えている慈悲の瞑想はなんとなく祈りっぽいんですね
これ変えよう変えようと思ったっても
日本語の動かせる範囲ではなかなかできないんです
それで私は 我々はどうやって慈悲の瞑想するのかと
今も講演中考えてみたんですね
そうすると 向こうは祈りの気持ち入ってないんです
慈悲の瞑想に なんかすごいかっこいいことやってるんだというポジティブなんです
あの言葉の使い方 それであって
前ですごいポジティブ的なことをやると自慢げにするんですよ
慈悲の瞑想 うるさいんです
慈悲の瞑想をやっちゃうと自慢するんだからね
あの連中は お祈りしちゃうと自慢できないでしょ
だから この日本語の言葉ではちょっと問題がありますけど
皆様は慈悲の瞑想は祈りではないと
あれはポジティブ転換なんです
心にポジティブフィードバックさせているんです
はい あの 今まであのやったのは
ここまでは生きる世界の訓練です
だって自分で頑張らなくちゃ
仏教は生かされる 生きてみなさいという世界ですからね
生きる世界の訓練です
生かされる生き方 次に勉強しましょう
生かされているという考えの正しい使い方を学びましょう
はい あの勝手に生き生きられないんです
これって知ってることでしょ
現実ですね 食事をとる
仕事をする 勉強するなどの行為が欠かせないんですよ
自分勝手でいかないんです
それで食事をとるということになったら
決まり 決まり 決まりで何でも食べられませんし
きのこは食べられますけど
そのままは食べられないし
それで決まりができちゃって
焼くか 天ぷらにするか
いろいろ茹でるかとかね
食べる順番も出てくるでしょ
最初にデザート食べて
それから味噌汁になっちゃうと
もう最悪でしょ だから自分勝手で生きていられないんです
自然環境の中で どこかの国で
家族などの仲間の中で生きているでしょ
日本で生きていると言ったっても
このどこに生きているのかということの生き方ね
青森に行っちゃったらね
北海道に行ったら東京と違うでしょ
生き方は 同じ今日であっても
沖縄に沖縄に住んでいる人の生き方
東京に住んでいる人の生き方
北海道に住んでいる人の生き方
変わるんですよ わがままは通じません
それから国によって生き方は変わるでしょうに
日本での生き方はアメリカに行ったら通じません
中東のどこかの国に行ったらまた通じませんね
だからわがままは通らないんです
それから家族がいるでしょ
それ 各家族がそれぞれ同じじゃないんです
だから 自分の家族の条件に自分を合わせなくちゃあかんですね
だから覚えておいてください
私の生き方っていうのは成り立たないんです
私はこういう風に生きてみたいなと思ったら
まあどこかで森の中に隠れるしかないんですね
アフリカにでも行って
では アフリカのブッシュマンになったら自分の生き方で生きていられる
これ無理です 結局は成り立たないんです
山に隠れても 私の生き方で
私のわがままでは生きていられないんです
自分の希望で自我で生きることは成り立ちません
これ絶対無理です 自然環境の中でやっと生きているだけの人生です
ちょっと空気が汚れたらね
あの PPM 何でしたっけ？0.25のホコリが来たらとかね
わからないんですからね
でも死んでないんだからね
まあやっと生きてるんですよ
しかし 天の導きによって
神様の愛によって生かされていると思ってはならない
生かされてますよ デジタル的に具体的に世界を見ると生かされているんです
これは神という化け物の愛によって生かされているわけじゃないんです
天の導きによって生きているわけじゃないんです
目の前の具体的な環境によって生かされているんです
服は何枚着るのかっていうことは
環境が決めてくれるんです
北海道やら北の青森の方に行ったら
まあもうちょっともう 1枚とかね
まあ手袋とか帽子もとかね
これでもうモスクワに行ったらもっと分厚いものという風になっちゃうんです
だから命令は誰がやってますかね
その場合は環境でしょ
天の導き なんだこれは
どこまでアホかと そういうことで
あの 生かされているとは
デジタル的に環境によって成り立つものです
あの遺伝子なんか中調べると
ものすごい複雑な構成でできていて
どんな時何をやるのかとかね
まあ遺伝子の中に一応決まっていて
その時その時そのタンパク質を作ってくれますね
小さい時と違って 例えば 14歳
15歳になってくると
成長期間に関わるタンパク質が生まれてきたり
年取ってくるとまた違うものになったり
いろいろでしょ これって素晴らしい
神様が計画立ててアホな話
あれは長い時間で進化する過程で
自然環境によって成り立ったものです
どんな変化があった方が生き延びるのかという
ただそれだけで だから面白がる
不思議がることって何もないんです
しかし わがままも通じません
こちら怪我したら周りいっぱい細菌さんたちがいるんだからね
入っちゃうと困りますね
だからバンドを貼っておく
他どうすることもできないんですよ
私はバンド貼りたくない
殺菌したくない 俺の勝手で来てるから
これ可能性で死んじゃいますからね
自我固定肯定の感情は末期状態になっている証拠ですね
この神様に愛されて 神様にありがたく生かされているんだ
だからハレルヤとかね
いう場合は あの人々のガンはもう末期です
もう治らないんです あまりにも自分を自我を肯定しているいるんですよ
私が言ったポジティブ宗教は逆で
私は恵まれているんだと
人間に生まれたことをすごい徳やと
だから崖から 蹴っ飛ばされたっても
全然貸せる気しかないぐらい幸せもんやと思うことと
神に導かれて思うことっていうのは違いますよ
こちらは客観的なデータに基づいている自信
向こうは妄想 病気により現れた自信なんです
それは巨大な妄想ですね
だから生かされてますよ
誰に 見たらわかりますね
勝手に生きていられません
こちらにいる場合は こちらの決まり守らなくちゃあかん
家に戻ったら 家の人々と話し合って生活しなくちゃあかん
会社に行ったら そちらの決まりでご飯食べようと思ったっても
また決まりが出てきて
自分が合わせるしかないんです
私たちは手で食べますけど
で だから言ってラーメンもらったらどうやって食べますかね
もう考えたんだよ ラーメンどうやって手で食べますかと
いくら手で 必ず私は必ず手で食べますよと頑固な人がいても
その人にラーメンあげたらどうするのかと
そんなわがままは通じませんよ
そういうわけで 環境が生かしているんですね
自分は すべてまとめても環境なんですね
家族も友達もみんな環境といえば環境です
責任の まだ残りありますね
責任逃れで無責任な生き方になります
この神に誰かに生かされているんだ
天に生かされているんだと思っちゃうと
それは責任逃れ 無責任な生き方なんです
家族にはちゃめちゃやられてるんだよと思った方がいいんです
わがままは通じませんよと
この自分の家族のせいでの方がよろしいんです
そうすると 自分たちはみんな自我を抑えてお互い仲良くするんですね
しかし 生きることは苦
生きることに戦わなくてはならない
生きることは苦であって
戦わなきゃ生きていられない
老いたくはないが 老いる
病にかかりたくはないが
かかる 損もする 失敗もする
希望している相手と結婚することはできなくなったりもする
このように客観的な事実に基づいて生かされているというフレーズを理解して
自我の錯覚を捨てる しっかりとデジタル的に思う
生かされている こういうことなんです
生きていられないんです
生かされているんです
環境によって 病気になりたくないでしょ
なりますから わがままは通じません
そういうわけで 皆様 今まで思っていた意味を変えてください
事象 生かされているとは
すごい客観的なデータなんです
デジタル世界です それで何をするのかというと
自我を捨てるんです 俺が俺の勝手に生きているんだぞという
あの錯覚 あれ 相当な錯覚です
今もそうやってないのに
これを捨てるんです はい
人生はルーレットです
人生は絶えず回るルーレットです
円盤に 8項目が書いてあります
ルーレットは回っています
項目は8あり 書いてあります
1 ラーブ 得すること  2 アラーブ
損すること  3 予想 名誉
いわゆる認められること
4 あやす 認められない
不名誉  5 パサンサー 褒められる
評価される 賛嘆される
6 忍耐 非難を受ける 却下される
自分のこと  7 苦患 幸福になる
成功する  8 ドゥッカ 不幸になる
失敗する   これは正しく生きる人は暗記するんです
我々は暗記しています
ラボはラボに愛想や装置は忍耐
パサンサ スカンとドゥッカ
これは乗り越えられませんよと
だからもう神にしたって
もう痛い筆でこと言えます
人生はルーレットなので
必ず狙ったターゲットに当たるわけはないでしょ
ルーレットのね  8項目のものを書いてね
賞品もあって 罰金もあるとかね
それで高級 1が 1に当たったら高級車で 2
に当たったらもう 500 万払いなさいと
もう狙うんだけど  1 はね
わからないんですよ どちらに当たるかと
常に回るルーレットの 8項目の一つには必ず当たるんです
ルーレットのあれで打っちゃえば
まあ一つには当たります
当たらないわけじゃないんです
それに悩んだり落ち込んだりするならば
知識のひとかけらもない人間です
であのあれ 弓をセッティングして回り
ずっとスピードにルーレット回っている
そこで自分が打つ 打ったらあのボードのどこかに当たる
それだけでしょう 何に当たったっても
悩んだりしていても 知識のひとかけらもないんです
だってそれわからないんだから
スーパーでもらったくじ券が当たったら嬉しいですが
はずれになっても悔しくはないでしょう
あるでしょう クリスマスの時とか
なんかぐるぐるぐるぐる回ったら玉一歩落ちるとかね
まあほとんど当たらないんですね
あれは でも誰も悔しがらないでしょ
なんとなく楽しいでしょ
はずれでも 自分の人生はこのように見るべきです
この 8項目を覚えておいてください
これはルーレットです
どちらに当たるかわからない
宝くじを買ったからといって
必ず 1 等賞当たるはずはないんですからね
理性のある人は 人生はルーレットであることを認めます
だからくよくよしない
不幸のところに当たったっても
今はちょっと状況はまずいなとかそれで終わっちゃいます
生かされているセクションはそれで終了です
だからこの狙って一応当たりますとかね
無理や こんなのは ルーレットだからいつだって回ってるし
ずーっとね 朝はもう幸福に当たっても 1
時間経ったところで不幸のところに当たる可能性もあるし
で 12時あたりで損という得というところに当たったかもしれませんだけど
1時  1時になってくれたら損というところに当たる可能性もあります
だからそんなのは放っておけばいいでしょ
生きると生かされるの調整
毎日必ずなまけず幸福になるようにと努力する
しかし 人生には生かされている側面もあることは決して忘れません
我々は生きることにもう90%頑張っちゃいます
100%頑張ります  100%頑張っても生かされ
生かされているところもあります
そこを覚えておきます
この人は何が起きても幸福に生きるんです
しかし ブッダの実践で智慧が現れて人格向上するので
ルーレットの影響に関係なく
確実に幸福を実現するんです
これでブッダのこの道を歩んでみると
人生は幸福になるか不幸になるか
そんなのはどうでもいいことなんです
結婚できるかできないか
どうでもいいんです あれはルーレットだからね
しかし この実践をやると智慧が現れるんです
理性が現れてくるんです
心が清らかになるんです
だから確実に成功するんです
確実に幸福を実現するんです
お釈迦様がこの 100%の確率性で幸福になると言ったのは
あの損避けて得だけの人生のことじゃないんです
病気は絶対なく 健康でいられるという
このくだらない ありえない
自然法則に逆らったことではなくて
別なものなんです ということで
今日の話はそれで終了になります
もうすべて説明しました
幸福の法則  仏道は失敗はありえない道です
はい 以上です はい どうもありがとうございます
あの ちょうど先ほど慈悲の瞑想は祈りではないけれどおっしゃいました
私は慈悲の瞑想を毎日唱えているんですけれども
祈りの気持ちで唱えていたように思います
スリランカの慈悲の瞑想はどのようなニュアンスのものなのか
教えていただけますでしょうか
あのスリランカの瞑想をそのまま日本語にできればやって
もうとっくにやっているはずなんですけどね
この言葉っていうのはね
まあ言語によって使い方いろいろありますから
まあどのようにとして紹介するのは難しいんですけど
ただ気持ちだけ説明できますね
現実として認めるというね
いわゆる当たり前の当然のことを生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにというと
なんか現実ではなくて
なんか希望みたいなものになっちゃうんですね
そうではなくて 生命はみんな平和であるべきです
あるはずですとかね 幸せであると私は思うこと
そう思うことが法則ですというようなニュアンスなんですね
向こうだったらサッビーサッターボンサッタっていうのはね
そのまま向こうの言葉で言いますからね
このバワンとって 動詞にはいくつかの意味がありまして
希望するって意味もありますけど
まあ当然のことでしょうと
それ続けてほしいんだから
バワンとになっちゃうんですね
例えば今日はいい天気ですねと言ったら
まあそんな感じで当たり前なんですけど
まあ良い天気続けても構わないんだから
その場合はバワンとっていう動詞にすんですね
まあ今日はいい天気ですけど
まあ明日もいい天気 明後日もいい天気であってほしいなとかね
であってほしいというと希望になっちゃうんだけど
まあそこも難しいですね
この言語変わると ですから私はずっとこの生命は誰だって褒めてほしいし
認めてほしいし どんな生命だって幸せになりたいし
殺されてほしくないし
貶されてほしくないし
ですから 私はそれは生命の基本的な権能であると
人権であると日本語で言うでしょ
スリランカ人にはこの人権とかそんなくだらんことを言わなくてもね
笑われちゃいますね 向こうは人権のことをすごく怪しげな単語で見ているんですね
なぜならば 西洋でこの人権という言葉を使って人の人権を奪ってますから
それはそのまま見ているんですね
人間の人権をはっちゃめちゃ破ったのは西洋人なんですね
国さえも奪っちゃいますからね
どこかに説教あったら行ってなんとかしてそれを取って取っちゃう
行って取られた後に人権のことを教えるのは
あなた人権を守りなさい
民主主義になりなさいよと
だから我々アジア人 スリランカの場合は
この人権とヒューマンライツという言葉を聞いただけで超気持ち悪くて
お似合いかと この人と思っちゃいますけどね
しかし ジャイナ瞑想の場合はそうじゃなくて
すべての生命は幸せで幸せでいたい
幸せを目指して生きている
だからこれ 生命の人権なんですね
人権っていうのは別に祈る必要ないでしょう
認めるだけでしょう 認めて人権を破らない
だからこの生命の人権であるという気持ちでジャイナ瞑想するんですね
だから自分たちがすごくいいことをやってますって
頑張ってるんですね なんでそれ人権だったら放っておけばいいんだけど
生命のもう一つのがりもあって
自分の人権は守りたいんだけど
他人の人権は全くも気にしない
自分が美味しいものを食いたいんだから
一発でもうもう 100匹ぐらいの魚取っちゃいますね
小さな魚だったらね なんとかちっちゃくあるでしょ
いろいろ だから箸でなんか白いなんとか魚がありましてね
箸で取ってもまあ 20匹ぐらい入ってますからね
それって命ですからね
だからそれは普通の生き方
そういう生き方なんですね
自分が生きていきたいんだけど
他人の人権っていうのは知ったことじゃない
だからライオンがね ガゼルをヌーという牛をね
食べたりするんだけど
ライオンはヌーにも生きる権利がありますよというところまでは考えていない
いや 動物だから考えていますけど
弱いものを一匹取れる取れればいいんじゃないかなと
弱いもの一匹取って食べて
他のものを逃がしてあげますけどもね
人間はより恐ろしくて生かしてあげないんですね
そこはおかしいと 人権はすべての生命に平等にあるんだと
それは知っておけと いうことで
しかし 普通はこれ知るのは知ること難しい
自分の人権だけ 西洋人と同じく
他の人間に人権がないんだけど
自分たちにすごく人権があるというね
だからまあ 例えばね 魚も生命であると
鶏も生命であると みんなに生きる権利があるんだと言ったら
なんか人間としての自分の都合が悪くなってくるんですね
困ったな どうしようかと
だから じゃあ忘れちゃえよということで
とんでもない恐ろしい人間になります
都合が悪くても それに関係なく
道はこれであると理解して
生命が生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと念じるんですね
そんなこと言ったら あなたちょっと都合が悪くなりますねと
まあそれもそうなんですけど
人権とか 人権は認めますということでね
そんな気持ちでやってますね
まあ祈りというか 現実に確認
現実の確認 他の瞑想と比較するとわかります
あの死の瞑想あるでしょ
死死随感というね 生きるものは死を向かって生きている
すべての生き物は死を向かって生きていると
当たり前のことでしょ
それを念じるんですね
そうすると自分も生きるとは
死を向かって動くことなんですね
だから 生きることに頑張れば頑張るほど
死がどんどん早く近寄ってくる法則ですね
法則です それは それをごまかしなくしっかり認める心を作るんです
その場合でも 私は死にたくない
私は死にたくないという原始脳の無意識の勘違いがあるんですね
だって存在欲があるんだからね
存在欲から事実と逆らったとんでもない勘違いが生まれるんです
生まれる 死にたくはないんだよと
まあ気持ちとして死にたくはないかもしれませんだけど
法則としては死を向かって生きているんです
その中に祈り全くないでしょ
だから生命 すべての生命が死を向かって生きている
いかなる生命であっても
死を向かって生きている
死は避けられない 生きることは不確かですが
死はだけに死のみが確かですと
何の祈りもないでしょ
別に祈らなくたっても
同じレベルな慈悲の瞑想も
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにというフレーズも
すべての生命は死を向かって生きているんだというフレーズは同じレベルなんです
価値が でも文章になってくると
一つなんか祈りっぽくなったりするんですね
これ どうやって日本語で変えるのかと
私はよくわからないんですね
ように読ませばいい 生きとし生けるものが幸せであります
それはまずいんです  そういう提案もあったんですね
どれかまた日本のお坊さんがね
幸せでありますというふうにね
提案したこともありますけど
私はそれ取れなかったんですね
それはまず嘘でしょ  嘘なのは自我が嘘だと思わせてるから
ん？何？ちょっと聞こえな
い 幸せでないと思わせてる
いえ 生きることは苦だから
誰だってハチャメチャ頑張らないと生きていられないんですよ
生きることは苦なのは自我があるからです
自我がなくても私のお腹も空きますよ
それ苦しいんだけど 料理も作らなくちゃいけないしね
誰かがただで料理を作ってくれるわけでもないしね
だから生きることは ミミズであろうか
微生物であろうか それだけでもかなり戦いで負けたら死んじゃうでしょ
動物は 人間だけですね
ちょっと生きる競争で負けても死なないのは
他の生命は生きることで一回負けたら死んじゃいますね
だから我々は楽しくご飯食べてますけど
生き物が一回餌を食べるということは
もう命かけてますね ちょっとでも失敗したらもう死んでるんだから
ですから 生きることは苦っていうことは
精密的な事実なんですね
ですから この瞑想から智慧を開発しなくちゃあかんでしょ
だから生きることは幸せでありますというふうに簡単に決めちゃうと
また道が壊れてしまうんですね
仏道は完璧 完璧な道でなければダメなんですね
だから 小さな すごくもう大したことない瞑想を始めても
そこはそのまま解脱まで続けるようにと完全たる道で作っているんですね
だから楽じゃないんですよ
言葉使うのは だったら
すべての生命に幸福に生きる権利があると念じなくちゃあかんです
私はそれを認めて生きてみます
そうすると OK なんです
でも 瞑想文章としては長すぎ
一切の生命に生きる権利がある
私はそれを素直に認めます
と言えば 生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにという文章が祈りから外れますね
外れてただ正しい瞑想になります
でもちょっと文章的にちょっと長すぎということもあります
もう一つ なんで私はまあ幸せでありますようにということにしたのかというと
やっぱり原文ででも あの同じ動詞が期待する動詞に希望する動詞にも使います
ババントという場合は期待いう場合もババントなんですね
そこで私が期待として生命が幸せになってほしいと思うのはよい期待でしょ
だから悪くないんですね
だからいくら頑張っても
あの文章 あのまんまで残っちゃいます
そこで注意は幸せでありますようにと自分が期待してただけで幸せにはなりませんね
そういうところだけですね
私は希望しますと それでまあ生命は生命の業で生きているんだから
まあそれはよくわからない
人が病気になったらね
早く治りますようにと希望はしますけど
その人 その病気で死んじゃうかもしれません
私が祈ったのにということはあり得ないんですね
私は慈悲の瞑想してあげたのに
やっぱり死んじゃったと
関係ないんで それは 病気の人に対して慈悲の瞑想するのは私の義務ですからね
仕事ですから それはやります
それでその人の業が良ければ
私の慈悲の瞑想の力が通じて治りますよ
治ります だからといって 100% 治るということはわかりません
業も絡んでるんだから
この間のスリランカでね
すごいガンで もうもうひどい状態で
本人がわかってないんだけど
状況を見たらね もう放っておいた方がいいという状況なんですけど
で 病院にお見舞いに行きましたけど
まあ私は普通はどうですかね
あれやこれや普通の話ししただけで
隣のベッドに子供がいたんですね
ものすごい行儀のいい
正確な子供で気に入っちゃったんですね
で 同時になんでこんないい子が病気になるのかと
もう腹が立ったこともあってね
子供がなんであんたいるのかと聞いたら
何か呼吸のところで何か問題ある
状態でね その時もうあの子にちょっとお経でもあげて祝福したいなって気持ちが生まれてきたんですね
しかし 隣のベッドにいるお坊さん
あれお坊さんでしたけど
お坊さんにはお経あげて祝福したくないんですね
したくないっていうのは
このしたくないって意味じゃなくて
そんなのをやったっても意味がないんですね
だから その人が自分の病気状態を確認しなくちゃいけない
この間も電話あってね
私はもういやで いくら治療したっても
もう何のこともなくて
もう毎日お経をあげているのに
なんだらかんだらお経もあげているのに
なかなか病気がいい方向に行かないんだとかね
もうもう死にたい気持ちでいるんだとかね
で 私はものすごい厳しいことを怒鳴ったんですね
あんたら方はね 死にかけていたっても
ブッダの道には入らないつもりですかと
なんて気持ち悪いことですかと
ここまで頭がおかしいんだったら
あなた死んじゃっても直行地獄に落ちますよと
いい加減にしなさい なんでその言葉はと
あんた病気治る 治してほしいとあげているお経は全部あれ
お経の使い方さえ間違ってるんだと
結局はブッダさえ侮辱しているんだと
だったらあげたければ
こういうこういうお経をあげなさいよと
それは病気治るためじゃなくて
あなたの汚れた心を直すためにやりなさい
はっきり言ったんです
あなたの病気で明日死んじゃっても私は気にもしないんだ
でも知ってる坊主として
あなた地獄に落ちるのは見たくはないんだと
だから心直しなさいよと
明日死んじゃってもいいんではないかって気分になりなさいよと言ったんだから
その人でではお経あげますということはちょっと成り立たないでしょ
でも 隣のベッドにいる子供にはやっぱり
お経あげて祝福した方がいいなっていうことは
もうエネルギが湧いてくるんですね
なぜかというと まだ子供でしょうし
業がね 幸福に生きる業が残っているし
そこをちょっと失敗があったら
そこに油を入れて ちょっとうまくいくようにしてあげるのが仕事を
私たちの仕事です まだ子供はすごく行儀作法が良くて
性格が良くて もうお経をあげたらすごく子供らしく素直に受けるでしょ
効き目があるんですね
あ お坊さんがお経上げてくれた
楽しいって それだけですからね
私は買い上げてくれたとかね
やはり素直に喜んじゃうんだから
お経のパワーがすぐ慈悲のパワーがすぐ効くんです
でもその人にやっちゃうと
隣のお坊さんのことをどうしようかと
で そうすると同じあのワードにまあまあ 10人ぐらい患者さんたちがいたんだから
どうせ病気になってる人はね
みんな祝福してほしいと思っちゃうでしょ
やるならば みんなに あの病棟にいたみんなに祝福してしなくちゃいかんし
それだったらいろいろ準備があるんだから持っていかなかったしね
まああんまりなかったことにするそうという
その代わりな子供をね
ちょっと抱いてあげて
まあ抱く大きい子でしたけど
もう背中を叩いてね しっかりね
頑張ってねとかね まあすぐなりますからとかね
微妙に短く ちょっと祝福しましたけどね
はい そういうことで言いたいところは
人が病気になったら これは病気が早く治りますようにと思うのは当たり前でしょ
それも慈悲なんですけど
だからといって病気が治るか治らないかっていうこと
生きる生かされる 両方ですからね
人生は だから生きるセクションで祝福して
慈悲の瞑想もして できることを全部やる
しかし 生かされるところではもう知ったことじゃないんですね
はい そういうことだから
まあ一応慈悲の瞑想にはなんとなく微妙に祈りのニュアンスが入っているのも全然構わないんです
だからこれ祈りですということだけは忘れてほしい
これは瞑想です 慈悲の瞑想です
慈悲の祈りですではないんです
祈りは仏教から見れば邪教です
言葉は祈りっぽくなったっても
これは知ったことじゃないんだから
日本語の問題だからね
皆様の責任じゃないんです
だから瞑想ですと覚えておけば直すと思いますね
だからスリランカ人がどのようにやっているのかっていうことは
ちょっと教えたってもね
そういうやり方でやってますけど
だからそれスリランカの子供たち使っている言葉そのまま日本語ができれば
もうとっくにやってますから
これ全部考えておいたんですよ
祈りなく 堂々と慈悲をやってますから
みんな だから祈りの場合は基本的には誰かに頼む構成なんですね
誰かに頼む だから祈りがこの神を信仰する宗教の世界から現れたんだだから
仏教の世界でも大乗仏教になってくると神々がいるんだからね
いろんな仏様 仏様というね
そういう存在は自分よりすごく偉くて
ものすごい力を持っていて
何でもできそうですね
観音さんとかね そうなってくると
偉い人にお願いするんだから
それが祈りなんですね
この場合は生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと言ったところで
あのね あんたそれは誰に誰に頼んだんですかと聞いてみてください
例えばキリスト教の方が隣にいた
それで仏教の人が生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと言ったら
キリストの人はあのね
あんたそれ誰に頼んだんですか？といや
別に誰にも頼んでない
だったらあなたの言葉は無意味
私がイエス様 マリア様
神様 もうこの人の病気が治りますように
幸せでありますようにと祈っているんだから
これは効き目があると言うんです
私はちゃんと責任者に頼んでいます
あんたただ自分で言ってるだけやと
効き目がないんやと思っちゃう
でも違いますけどね 本当は
だから祈りとは誰かに頼むという形から現れて発展しています
真理を認めるということは違うんです
現実を認める 事実を認める
地球が丸いというような感じなんですね
地球が丸くなりますようにではないんです
でも丸いんだからね そういうわけで
生命が幸福であるってあるんじゃないんですね
幸福であるならば 仏教もいらなくなっちゃいますね
なんで解脱を目指して頑張っているんですかね
結局は幸福でないからでしょ
ではなくて 生命は幸福を目指すぞ
すべて それが事実です
目指しているんだから
まあそこで失敗しない方がいいでしょう
だから生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにということの真理が
生命が幸せを目指しているんですね
そこは守ってあげなくちゃあかん
邪魔してはいけません
できるならば協力する
できることなら邪魔しない
迷惑かけない 人権を守ってあげる
幸せになる そういう知恵的なアプローチを育てることが慈悲の瞑想なんですね
だから 瞑想であって祈りではないんです
まあ理論言っちゃうと面倒くさいんですよ
だから理論なく ただ唱えればいいんです
とにかく 唱えていくと
どんどんどんどん心が変わっていきます
はい 以上です  はい ありがとうございました
えーと すいません ちょうど四時半の時間になってしまいましたので
本日はこれで終了したいと思います
最後に皆さんで廻向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 廻向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッミッティヨイワジャンとサンベルーウィナッサトーマーテーラワーダヨスキーディーガーイコーガヴェーバトゥサッブマンガラングラッカンとサッブデヴァタサッ
ブビンダヌバーヴェーナサダーサッティバワントゥテーバトゥサッブマンガラングラッカンとサッブデヴァタサッブダンマヌバーヴェーナサダーサッティバワントゥテーバトゥサッブマンガラングラッカンと
サッブデヴァタサッブサンガヌバーヴェーナサダーサッティバワントゥテー
アビワーディナシーリスサヤニッチャンバッダーパチャイノーチャッターローダンマヴァッダンティヤーユアンノースカンバラン
アーユラーローゲサンパッティサンガサンパッティニーレジェアトーニバーナサンパッティイミナーテーシャミンユトゥ
サーディーサーディーサー
はい ありがとうございます